ragazzi questa roba è
oltretutto di call of duty battlefield
bebè nel cesso
questo è lo sviluppo videoludico nel
siamo su and simulator la cosa [ __ ] e
che c'è il multiplayer sebbene tu devi
muovere una mano per fare cose in
multiplayer la cosa potrebbe essere
divertente
buongiorno cosa bisogna fare nello
schiacciare il pulsante aree di non
mettere di ok con la mano fatto ma io
non so come fuse wimm one a vincere
quello che rimane vivo va bene come ci
si muove ma che che ombra vedo ma io non
come ci si muove è quelli si girano come
fanno a girarsi a devo caricare con i
missili sta roba va bene ho dei problemi
alle articolazioni in questo momento
allora calmi tutti è così fa ma io non
ci arriva neanche i missili ragazze
certo problema ma non ci arrivo non li
posso prendere prendi il missile quanti
problemi
ciò i sandali prendi il missile da melo
gli altri per caso stanno per sparare no
perché non ho fatto ancora niente mano
guardami non siamo amici ed è però mi
devi cagare
come ho fatto come ho fatto a muovermi
come come lo aspetta come come ho fatto
la rotella delle nostri forma ok adesso
vado dagli altri e mi scusi guardi che
lei non può vincere perché non è
possibile a posso anche correre barak e
figo va bene adesso che so come ci si
muove tutta un'altra storia
vediamo alla prendi il missile
prendi il missile prendilo no no non
ballare micheal j prendi il mis prendi
lo educa bravo chiuditi bravissimo no no
no che cade no che cade vabbè frate le
ma tutte e due usa le tute usa l'altra
anche se no un casino come lo prendi
l'ho preso
secondo me io salto in aria da solo il
mio padre
forse è meglio che stia zitto in queste
circostanze
va bene cambiamo cambiamo però è
un'altra roba salve ho questo mi sembra
più carino perché liste togliendo i peli
alla schiena cosa vedo che è brutto come
il biliardo
ok dove troviamo giocabile va bene lo fa
eco vedi l'ho presa stavolta stai
lontano no no non si fa limbo col mio la
mia roma stecca no si fermano chi sei tu
pelato toglietevi dalla mia vista per
cortesia come si fa a muoversi muoviti
brava via via via via schifo cioè sembra
una riunione tra premi nobel
comunque non vorrei dire le famiglie
dere fare guardi come sono a loro agio
in questo gioco cosa cosa aveva ai a
testa di culo che male si fa riprendere
la come faccia prendere le cose g porca
vacca la mia questa comunque puoi stare
fermo con quella staccata la infilo
nell'occhio
c'è qualcuno mi spiega chi ha inventato
sta roba per cortesia ma che è cioè
veramente la cosa più trash che abbia
mai visto
vabbè lasciamo perdere
se questa è un'altra mappa oh che bello
c'è più o meno rei di lady sono pronto
vai facciamo qualcosa di decente dunque
è veramente al processo gioco la fuga
ragazzi il gioco sta che il primo che si
fa fuori the winner is e la survival e
prete il vincitore l'ultimo
sopravvissuto devo caricare la cappa che
la vedo dura ho caricato ho caricato no
ma mi ripassi il fucile è per cortesia
l'ho perso secondo me non doveva andare
così però posso muovermi ma non puoi
muoverti porca vacca
cosa posso fare per vinti lancio il
caricatore spero che ti arrivi in testa
che non posso vincere in altro modo
amici non mi fate del male vengo in pace
come si fa ecco paga la mossa ecco
l'aspetto ce l'ho ce l'ho ancora un'arma
ragazzi volendo eccola questo perfetto
prendi il braccio usato come arma
cosa è perfetto kira lo che tristezza di
vita si aveva prima che qualcuno
sparring sta partita ci si mette un anno
e mezzo rega allora li mortacci
riproviamoci mettimi chiccoso mettilo è
uno prendi arma 2 no e poi già sparare
via così per premere il grilletto ma se
funziona
c'è un tastino che serve a togliere il
caricatore ma va a cagare che ne so io
porca [ __ ] ci ho messo una vita a
veri proviamoci o come ho fatto
come è possibile è però non ho sentito
il click e quindi dovresti spingerla un
pelo non tocchiamo più quel pezzo
dobbiamo caricare l'arma quindi tira giù
usa l'altra mano per cortesia ok
carichiamo no carica l'arma carica la
teoria dovresti tirare questa fare qui
se non erano pieni non mi tieni da
questi bastioni spariamo stai fermo qua
la mano e vai lo stai per morgan cosa
sta succedendo su capri e come ha fatto
a uccidermi quello allenato direttamente
puntin di mortacci tua
lo spa come ha fatto a sparare fammi
capire come di un'ora che tentavo di
caricare l'arma ma uccidilo almeno che
ammazzi solo me tanto io in sandali c'è
se proprio vogliamo metterla che soldato
incredibile va dai ragazzi proviamo nei
ancora un'altra che vedo che che una
meglio dell'altra appunto c'è una pizza
questo è il mio tasto comunque vorrei
cliccarlo io faccio rally anche per te
grande food on the table e nei kit falso
che di mangiare velocemente va bene il
tipo di fianco a me non è che sia
proprio uscendo questa cosa però va bene
come faccia mangia mangia mangia è
cacciato il server programmare un altro
ragazzi sempre a caso del set by cosa
dobbiamo fare qua innanzitutto kikar
eredi ok la cosa facciamo viene lanciare
le bombe aprì la scatola uccidili il
vincitore sarà l'ultimo sopravvissuto
siamo in due quindi il primo che si
ammazza abbia scatola adriatica io ci ho
dei problemi anche solo la pena la
scatola figurati ecco
tira tira tira bravo ci sono e grana
prendi no cosa c'è non vale come coach
avevano in mano a come la linguetta ma
se il molli la cala [ __ ] granata che
linguetta tiri tirato la linguetta
magagna dati non c'era non riesco a
prenderla regala impossibile quello tira
le granate senza tirar linguetta un
genio e fammi vincere una partita
tanti problemi allora alza alza alza per
falsa e faceva una roba bella ti puoi
staccare linguetta schifano è che un
ingegnere sei fermati che te devo
uccidere dai la tua madre stavo facendo
giusto solo perché non sai perdere
cribbio strinsero la mano di sinistra
stai fermo
[Musica]
signori la maestria si vede anche dalle
piccole cose che ho messo ansia perché
ho troppo bravo riesplosa la granata in
mano va bene
c'era anche questo la mettere in conto
giustamente ho vinto una partita almeno
oggi almeno quello comunque ragazzi
questo delle bombe il più figo è più
semplice più che altro quello che riesco
a fare anch'io alla volta ci siamo non
possiamo non esserci
stai fermo croce cosa sta facendo
tira la lingua e la lingua no con la t a
una granata la linguetta tirata quello
dai veloce veloce bianche quello tiri
veloce stai fermo con l'altra mano devi
stare fermo gesù cioè io c'ho dei
proventi dalle linguette ma porco
demonio schifoso l'aido morto ma se cosa
ci fai a lingue cosa fai
va beh ma basta sentita rancio così è
schiatta seta è stata la linguetta così
come roba lì si sa non c'è bisogno di
tori alla linguetta ma va a cagare
un'ora che ma dov'è il mio avversario ma
come mi sparito all'avversario mente tra
accordo sapete fare un gioco normale che
bastava tirarla granata
tua madre che ne so io novara per chi ha
fuori la linguetta per bastava
semplicemente toglie alla grana traversa
per lo prima
vabbè ragazzi devi provare l'ultimo per
oggi che batte royale che tra tutti
quello che ancora non l'ho visto ok
partire partiamo questo and butter
royale tra l'altro qui c'è quello che
rimane vivo va bene a stento riesco a
muovermi sto gioco sembra uno zombie tra
l'altro abbassa le braccia per cortesia
mi guarda mi accontento del coltello
perché non credo di riuscire a
maneggiare le altre armi quindi va
benissimo così
eccola ecco non mi ha visto lo uccido
sono state mi ha visto c'era anche lui
c'era anche lui
la smetta az non va lontano da ti
ammazzo da ma non ti azzardare avvicina
è dopotutto ai colpisci e non riesco a
colpirlo aiuto l'hack è male aveva
colpito temi ag story the stories aido
mount kg detto in un inglese veramente
maccheronico ma se ti avvicini a con un
po commenti suicidio non so se lo sai
zio è un coltello si si era 6 scemo e
scemo da 1 a 1400 scemo va bè ragazzi di
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto è
veramente stupendo hun sen simulator
però come potrebbe essere fatto un po
meglio
non so che cosa che manca ma qualcosa
manca tipo le ossa come al solito mi
piace anche 28 al comitato scrizione
senza vestiti scarpe e non ci vediamo da
ragazzi
[Musica]